yeah king h6 played luke h4
check rook h5 only move queen f8 queen f
no queen of it
queen g7 queen fade on the board if king
g5 queen f4 is made so you have to go
queen g7 here
and where is the mate peter well we are
queen f4 g5 only move
and what are we missing our queen d6
queen g6 queen f8 winning the queen yeah
we're gonna see this on the board
oh this is beautiful this is so
stunning and wesley smiling uh
what an incredible end that was just
provoking the move
g5 taking away the defense of the h5
rook from the
pawn because peter let's just show that
if you go rook h5 before you provoke g5
black simply captures
with the pawn if we just back up peter
would be the what king queen e8 king g7
queen upstairs
and queen to f5 maybe oh my god
the incredible oh my oh my god
and look at magnus i'm drifting it all
the time you remember i told him he
should take on d6 because his brain
doesn't work anymore and then he
magnus blunders the mate incredible
magnus is so angry what a game played by
magnus berindi and wesley
we have action on the board so wesley
did play the move c5
look easy look d6 there was nothing else
he has to hang on to his e6 pawn
but now magnus just takes the c5 pawn
after 2k16
makes good use of the default setting to
enter with luke d6
and wesley designed yeah there is no no
way to put defense
yeah so strange game yeah yeah magnus
done it again
whenever he loses he wins the next game
it's just incredible i mean we might be
talking about
he's struggling he's not in his best
shape zone
but he still does it incredible
okay but is it really over vlad like
black has nothing here
at all or are we missing anything
has six minutes on the clock i think
he's just shocked i mean he was
he was dreaming of bouncing back but i'm
pretty sure that he was not sure that he
will be able but
now he's served uh served on the silver
plate this chance
mm-hmm bishop b5 is also possible
no but now rook h5 or something yeah i
know magnus resigned i mean okay he just
cannot take this anymore it's just
and wesley just leaning back and uh
four decisive games it's been a crazy
day
vlad what what are your impressions
about this match
peter what an incredible day we've had i
know you and vlad were very chess hungry
waiting for the playoffs no playoffs
today but the drama of these four games
was
absolutely incredible well i mean you
can actually play the move knight d5
check because it
means that white can never come closer
with his king because of the check yeah
knight d5 on the board
and f3 and wesley has still enough he
resigns
because that's it bishop dc and and he
simply cannot do anything just king b2
bc and
slowly pushing and cleaning the whole
three immediately right
no yeah you can go b3 immediately yeah
you can yeah that's the elegant way i
mean but
yeah and mango's designed
that's it we do have a match on our
hands peter it's
one one and whoever was writing wesley
off after that game won
not so quickly he's leveled the score
peter that was an incredible comeback by
wesley with the black pieces
yeah i will have some bishop c1 check in
my pocket yeah somewhere but kenji seven
at least i want to make about 97.95 yeah
that looks
that looks nice what a line what an
incredible line
yeah but we have to get back to the game
because it's quite dramatic ah maybe we
will see a repetition of moves
yeah and it's draw the game is drawn
oh wow um yeah well
i don't know i don't know uh maybe
somebody will wander something here
still no
it's a draw yeah that's it that was a
bit of a non-event
the game for and um
yes both players happy to take it to
playoffs bishop p2 or bishop f1 and just
bring it on to this diagonal and it's
over
that's it that's it wesley so does it
magnus resigns not without
difficulty i would say
wow but he also takes on c1 i don't know
why not knight takes d5 first
and that's it that's it that is
oh my god yeah yeah no it's clear that
magnus was
in this tiebreak was really today yeah
was really not there yeah because yeah
very strange mistakes but okay it was
well
and magnus so disappointed and angry
with how it's gone you can see it just
the exhaustion and the anger right now
and wesley saw is the champion of the
first leg of the champions chess store
this killing open he's the winner he
goes back with thirty thousand dollar
what a phenomenal performance by him
magnus carlsen
finishes in second place with fifteen
thousand dollars